- [David] Hello, readers.
Today I'm gonna be talking
about text features.
Which is to say, the parts of a text
that aren't just words.
We look at text features to
get a better understanding
of what the text is all about.
Although they're not words.
Like I said, text features
help our reading comprehension.
So what's a good example
of a text feature?
Well, let's start with, ah, say, a map.
Maps are a great example
of a feature of the text
that isn't made up of words.
So this is a social studies textbook.
This section is about Egypt.
I've turned to this page
where there is a map.
What is this map of?
Well, we can look at this part here.
This text here over on
the side is a caption.
It's something that can
tell us about an image.
And the map is labeled.
So it's about the Nile River
and how the Nile River is fed
from rainfall to the south,
the water travels to the north.
Here's Egypt up here.
Don't focus too much on the details
of this being about the Nile and stuff.
Really, what we're talking
about is here is an image,
there is a caption next to the image,
reading the caption helps us understand
what's in the image,
and looking at the image
helps us understand what's in the caption.
So we've got maps, we've got images.
And that can be illustrations, photos,
blueprints, anything really.
And if we go back to our
social studies textbook,
we can see here there's this image.
And just looking at the image on its own,
we might not be able to
tell what that is exactly.
But again, there is another
helpful little caption
over to the side that says
this is an aerial view of the Nile.
So now we know what this is.
And that can help ground us as we go
through the rest of the
text, which is also,
I assume, about the Nile
River an ancient Egypt.
The caption and its picture
are two halves of a whole.
They're both helping you
understand the other.
Other useful text features
include charts, diagrams,
and graphs, which can include
things like timelines.
This page here has a table.
You can see up at the top,
this top row is labeled Ancient Egypt.
And then on the left, we have
all the different periods
of Egyptian history.
And on the right, all the dates
associated with those periods.
There's also a timeline in this lesson.
And this one has a bunch of
different text elements, right?
So we have, it's not a
traditional-looking timeline,
but you can see that it's arranged
from top to bottom, oldest to most recent.
Those are just some of the many options
that are available to you
when you look at a text.
Remember that when
you're reading a passage,
it's not just the words,
it's everything on the page.
Sometimes I even like
to familiarize myself
with the charts or the diagrams
or the images on the page
before I start reading,
before I really get down
to the business of reading the paragraphs.
Because that helps me get rooted.
It helps me anchor myself
in what the text is gonna be about.
I look at the pictures,
I skim the captions
just to say, "Okay, what's goin' on here?
"Cool, we're talkin' about rivers.
"We're talkin' about ancient Egypt.
"I'm ready."
And building those skills of readiness
and being able to anchor yourself
in any text that you encounter
is what's gonna make you a strong reader.
You can learn anything.
David out.